[Music]
the costs of achieving net zero while
still vague are clearly big this week
the government announced some support a
5 000 pound subsidy for 90 000
households to replace their gas boilers
with heat pumps but the average cost of
a heat bump currently is around 10 000
pounds that's just one aspect of going
green
is this strategy fully thought through
i'm joined now by chris stark chief
executive of the climate change
committee and bob seeley the
conservative mp for the isle of wight
hi both thanks so much for joining me
chris to start with give us your
reaction to the government's
announcements this week
well we're 24 hours after the doc the
government dropped nearly 2 000 pages on
us so it's a huge amount of material to
process so i think i can only really
give you my early reaction to it but i
think broadly it's good um the
government has has been tasked with
setting out a plan for reaching net zero
and if you look what they've published
it's hard to say that they have failed
in that task they've clearly laid out a
detailed prescription in every area i
think the test for us will be the extent
to which the policies that are in that
plan will deliver against the ambitions
but the ambitions now i think are
broadly in the right place so that's
very exciting
bob i'm sure you've been making your way
through the many documents as well
what's your initial take
well like like chris i'm sort of doing
my best to speed read them and i start
with the executive summaries and then
sort of move from there into various
topics
i give the government its credit it's
trying to set noble goals it's trying to
do the right things
and zero carbon is is a great ambition
uh i i'm not sure i would quite go
as as far as chris to
to say that the ambition is is right
because i
i think like a lot of people i'm
slightly wary of some of the things that
we're
doing on the way to having hopefully
zero emissions at 2050 or at some point
relatively soon afterwards and my
concern is is not with the government's
intent because it's arts in the right
place and i think boris says the prime
minister had a very strong leadership on
this but
our ability to deliver and our ability
to effectively align common sense with
some of these policies because i i think
some of us are not just myself have
concerns about that and my i suppose the
political fear is that we are going to
confront a reality where we can't
deliver on this stuff it's going to get
very expensive and it's going to get
very politically unpopular
well chris what about one of those areas
of contention gas boilers seem to be on
the way out
and we know that this tried and tested
and cheap form of of heating our homes
is carbon admitting um but is the
alternative feasible anytime soon only
last month you were saying that heat
pumps are not yet ready for mass market
yeah i did say that and i stand by that
because at the time what i was referring
to was the fact that they are expensive
they're expensive there isn't an
installer community
of any great size in this country
and we haven't done it at scale now if
you look across the water in place like
germany they're doing a million a year
with similar climate not the same
climate but a similar climate they'll
have a different housing stock but their
own challenges there but
we see around the world that heat pumps
are a viable technology
so i think we are about to enter the
mainstream for heat pumps and i think
what the government has done this week
is is hastening that um by firstly by
offering some incentive
financial incentive for a relatively
small number of heat pumps to be
installed but crucially to make it clear
that by the mid-2030s they are aiming to
phase out the sale of gas spoilers which
gives us i suppose the market gives the
market a a trajectory now over the next
10 years or so to prepare for that
moment what we're not clear on yet
although there's some intriguing stuff
in the um in the pa in the documents
that have been published by the
government in the last few few days
is quite how we get from where we are
today which is about 30 000 heat pump
installations a year to where the
government wants to be by the end of
this decade which is somewhere between
hundred thousand and a million heat
pumps a year uh and it's interesting
that there's a there is one policy that
they didn't make much of yesterday which
is this obligation
uh that they would they would like to
put on the manufacturers of boilers
to raise over time the proportion of
heat pumps that are being sold in the uk
as a proportion of the total heat
installations that the uk
makes each year now that is a policy
that could really work we've seen that
work in for example uh california when
it comes to zero emission vehicles a
mandate they call it mandate for sales
there's a mandate for uh zero emission
vehicles as part of the package of
things that was announced uh yesterday
so that idea of mandates seems to be
back in fashion with the government i
suppose that might be one way in which
we can see that that large and very
rapid scale up that we would need over
the next decade and beyond
that's an interesting point chris
because there's been a lot of criticism
of the 5 000
subsidy to upgrade your boiler people
saying well that's not going to cover it
especially for low-income households and
the subsidies only estimated to reach
about 90 000 households and we're going
to need it to we're going to need
these upgrades to reach millions more
but you're saying that the timeline is
actually for the market it's so that
companies know where the government's
planning on going and hopefully that
brings with it innovation brings costs
down but there's no guarantee
no there isn't a guarantee and i think
that's a reasonable uh outlook on it and
and a reasonable point for you to make
uh the the scale-up that's required is
enormous i don't think we can escape
that uh you know the the the need to get
to something of the order of a million
low carbon heat installations per year
uh by the time we get into the 2030s
from where we are now is a huge task but
it was interesting i suppose in the in
the things that the government said
yesterday
you can see a fairly clear plan to put
the obligation on business on the on the
on the commercial uh operators in that
sector to try and deliver against these
targets and that that should put the
incentives in the right place to bring
down the cost for the consumer you're
absolutely right the 5 000 pounds per
heat pump isn't really going to touch
the sides
of this challenge overall but it's a
nice way to start over the next three
years so that should
make some headway i suppose and i can
see that that policy having an impact in
the overall mission that the government
has set of bringing heat pumps down to
cost parity with gas boilers and already
we've seen a response from some of the
the commercial operators notably octopus
energy who've stepped up to say that
they think that that can be delivered
even more quickly than than 2030 which
is the government's plan overall so we
may see now a race to install heat pumps
at a cheaper price for the consumer and
crucially
the kind of supply chain skilled supply
chain that we would need building up
alongside that i think that is actually
the bigger challenge is how you build
the installer community to the size that
we need it to achieve the the goals that
the uk has set
bob the prime minister's rhetoric seems
to have changed actually quite a bit in
recent weeks more acknowledgement that
this net zero target is going to need to
be seen through the prism of working for
the consumer and working for the
taxpayer and the government's actually
very lucky that um you know we're not
having the debates that we were having
15 20 years ago when i was a kid about
whether or not climate change exists the
question now is how exactly we go about
handling it and what the target is and
how soon it should come in and what the
costs are going to be
broadly speaking the public is on the
government side on the left and the
right voters care about climate change
but i guess my question to you is seeing
as the government's already been willing
to break certain manifesto promises to
increase taxes in areas that the public
consider important like the nhs
is the government going to be more
honest about the fact that you know
these changes come with a price tag and
actually taxes may have to go up again
in order to combat climate change um the
simple answer is as we can see from the
debate that's happening in the
newspapers i think the government is
divided on that and i think the treasury
is more concerned with uh more concerned
about this and other government
departments i think for me look it might
well be that when it comes to heat pumps
the the green energy schemes have quite
often failed in the past or the green
home scheme was not a success so
government schemes can still fail
what could well happen with heat pumps
is what happened with wind turbines that
when actually the market kicked in and
could produce economies of scale
actually the wind turbines have done
extremely well and it might be that in
10 years time there will be as chris
hopes and i hope there's going to be a
wide availability of heat pumps that
will be more efficient now because they
don't work for all homes um they're not
as efficient by a long way as as as
boilers and if you have to rip out all
your piping because your piping is wrong
for the enlarged radiators you're going
to need
there are a lot of complicating factors
here my worry is just i think we have to
we're losing a sense of perspective the
united kingdom is responsible for one
percent of emissions and yet somehow
we're told that because we have historic
responsibility because the industrial
revolution started here that we have a
responsibility to go further faster than
other people i'm sorry i just don't buy
that argument we if we got rid of every
bit of carbon that we emitted in this
country you'd go down from a hundred
percent to 99
and as long as countries like china are
emitting 30 percent uh
are responsible for 30 percent of
emissions a year i just think we've got
to pres um got to have a sense of
proportion and we've got to drop some of
the sort of quasi-religious further by
with which we're approaching this issue
we could decarbonize completely it is
not going to save the planet so we have
to have a sense of realism about what we
can do and how we go about it one other
example kate the government turned down
or the committee responsible to turn
down the jackdaw shells development of
the jackdaw field
in the north sea we are hoovering up
natural gas from other suppliers germany
is entirely well largely dependent 30
between 30 and 50 percent depending on
the figures depending on the type of
fuel from russia you know it is better
for us
even if we're still admitting to be
producing our own gas and potentially
supplying europe then have the
environmental and frankly security
hazard of that gas coming from other
states that frankly care much less about
climate change than we do chris
goss there's a lot to say about that i
mean i i think you're entirely right to
say that we are a small proportion of
global emissions but i think the the
idea of net zero is a fairly fundamental
one it's important to say that the
science says very clearly now that
globally we have to get to net zero or
we will keep warming the planet and
actually in recent years the science has
become even clearer on that including
notably the report from the ipcc in the
last few weeks now i suppose the point
here is that
there is an argument to say that there's
a historical legacy and that the uk
should address that with an early date
for net zero but it's not the argument i
would make i mean i think the argument
for net zero is that since the world is
on that journey there are huge economic
benefits to it so actually setting that
target and then and then and then aiming
for it it will create the new kind of
markets the new industries that will be
benefits to the people living in this
country and
in this transition and i think that's
the argument the government has made in
the net zero strategy that we saw
published yesterday it's also the
argument that china and others seem to
have accepted by wanting to supply into
that market now china is one of the
countries that has set a net zero goal
for 2060 as has the us as has the eu so
there is another argument here about the
trading bloc that's within that net zero
goal and we are definitely in it and
amongst the lead of it and maybe the
last thing i'll say is on energy
security of course net zero itself buys
the uk much greater energy security
by being dependent on the very plentiful
electricity supplies that we can have
from renewables we will be more energy
secure and nuclear in that mix too so we
are a lot less exposed to the kind of
imported price fluctuations imported
fossil fuels that we that we are exposed
to at the moment
i'm sorry chris just with great respect
to you on that last point for example
that is only true
in 20 or 30 years time provided we
actually grip you know the modular
nuclear reactors and build a lot of them
provided we increase wind power provided
we do stuff like invest in tidal wave
power so you know power from from from
from waves rather than lagoons but
actually for the next decade for the
next potentially 20 years we are giving
up energy security you look at germany
and i'm i'm in with you in spirit but
it's just about getting there and
actually having common sense here if you
look at germany they have given up
they're shutting the what the last of
their 17 nuclear power stations next
year they are importing and using their
own lignite brown coal they've gone from
being the clean man of europe to the
dirtiest man in europe they are
effectively paying for russian
rearmament
potentially for russia to reinvade
ukraine or to try to invade ukraine
again in the next year or next five ten
years and because we are becoming
increasingly dependent on gas fields
outside the uk we are actually
undermining our security including our
energy resilience and our energy
security because we're not continuing to
invest in our own gas fields it's the
same argument chris that i could make
about the idiocy
of offshoring or manufacturing to china
and then claiming we're becoming greener
half hour emissions as you well know
have come from well out of our emission
cuts half have come from shutting down
coal-fired power stations a very good
idea provided we have replacements half
have come because we've just outsourced
our industry to china and generally and
to other countries in that neck of the
woods and they are going to decarbonize
much more slowly than us so this whole
process of virtue signaling and almost
narcissistic sort of virtue signaling
about our own moral purity is actually
coming at the expense of making a
potentially adversarial state a richer
and b making the world dirtier because
they are not taking the same attitude to
climate change as we do so when you say
our security we're better off we are in
20 or 30 years time for the next decade
for the next 15 20 years we're actually
endangering our security as well as
exporting jobs to other countries and
potentially adversarial states it is a
policy that could have been written by
the russians and the chinese rather than
whitehall
chris i want you to come back to any
point that bob made there and and and
have your say and but i also want to ask
you about this short-term versus
long-term trade-off and the gains that
are to be made because we're in the
midst now of an energy crisis the cost
of living crisis is looming over so many
people in the uk and there's really no
getting around that and lots of people
are saying well nuclear can be the
solution in seven eight years time maybe
ten years time it can make the
transition much more comfortable but
others are saying well too little too
late how is that going to help us now
how do we get the balance right here
without having to roll back the progress
that has already been made in the uk in
trying to get to net zero while still
acknowledging that this is a very
difficult time for a lot of people who
would benefit from their bills going
down
well i mean there's again lots to say
about that i mean i think if
just as bob has acknowledged if we would
like to have the kind of
energy security that we will have in 20
years time through the policy of
approaching net zero then we have to
start on the journey somehow i mean i
think every year we build out that that
domestic capacity for generating the
energy that we use
every year we get closer to that goal so
i would say that is as good a time as
any to start now the other point i would
make is that um we have indeed done a
lot by decarbonising our power sector
we've also become much more energy
efficient as a sec as a as an economy
the outsourcing of of manufacturing
happened quite a long time ago now
actually you don't see that in the stats
um and in fact our you know the gross
valuation we get from manufacturing has
been has been growing over time so so
there is a chance here to be
decarbonized as a as a as a country and
to have decarbonized industry but we
can't just have that overnight and we
will need crucially policy to drive some
of that and to protect british industry
from the cost of that decarbonization
now i don't think we conduct that that
is a a major challenge that sits here it
relates to the other challenge that you
ask about about the cost of living and
um i you know i'm not going to dress it
up there are costs in this transition i
think the aggregate position is a very
positive one we have a very large
investment to make as an economy but a
growing saving from those investments as
we decarbonize but this is a big
challenge for the government i i'm not
going to deny it and the answer that we
got from
the government yesterday in the net zero
strategy is that they want to put the
onus on uh the on commerce and on
business to bring down the cost of this
transition
alongside limited public spending to
protect those who can least afford it
from it from those costs and
it remains to be seen whether that
strategy will work
i'm quite interested to see what the
chancellor will say in his spending
review and his budget next week i think
that's the piece that we haven't yet
seen that sits alongside the net zero
strategy but
it's it's a huge challenge i accept that
bob uh last question to you um to use
your words these virtue signaling
policies which you say could have been
designed in russia or china have indeed
come from your very own government so
are these the words that you would put
to your prime minister as well as to
viewers on spectator tv
well i mean i'm fairly blunt speaking so
people can you know take it or leave it
i thank chris for his honesty in this
because
these are noble ambitions and nobody is
doubting that but i just think our
desire to set an agenda and actually
deliver the reality of it is not coupled
up and chris is sort of he's saying he's
got the honesty to say it's a thank you
to him because there is going to be a
big price
and if we we're not going to have that
threat from labor because their you know
their stance is going to be similar but
actually there are going to be a lot of
people in the country who are going to
be coming worse off because this is
going to cost our businesses and it's
going to cost people as well and and
that politicians have to get re-elected
and i can what my concern is that we
will start rowing back from these rather
than being more realistic now about for
example being able to the need to use
gas and to continue to invest in our own
gas fields so we can supply ourselves
and potentially europe whilst we build
the modular rolls-royce nuclear power
stations say no to the ridiculous
untrust untouched untested chinese
designs which we should never be have
been contemplating this takes time and
we need to be more honest and i think
because of cop and because we are um
you know for a variety of reasons we are
i
i
think we're just our ambitions and our
goals are getting ahead of the reality
and i think politically i worry that
we're going to pay a price for that and
i want very much i share chris's goal
and the goals of the prime minister as i
said in our manifesto it's how we get
there and having the honesty to to
confront some of these bigger decisions
but also keep investing in gas in this
country rather than import it from much
more unstable and more unfriendly states
chris and bob thanks for joining us
[Music]
you